.
WEEK, MOCNN'S KYUNG LAH.ERY BUSY
>> Reporter:ME C
TIME W
LONGACCINATI
LINES IN M
>> I'M SAR
MAKEAPPOJU
>> Reporter: IN NEW YORK CITY, .
TYSER TWEETED VER SEEN THIS BEFT
HA AGAIN.
ICD
ITRIS SPECTACULAR SHOWS NCELLED.
ALL,CH PAST.
PEE
HOUR TO BEESTED AS OMICRONS RAP
COMING
YESTERDAY TWICD OT
BEING ABLE TO GEHOLE NEW
THE FACT THAT IT IS MOVING VERY
HAVE TO MOVE FASTER.
>> Reporter: PROLOG,
EWS MAYOR DEROUB       REDOUESI.
STP  IN NTE  CIDD THE E INCREASI
SHARPLY IN.
THS E OF 8
THIART  EXPERIENCE A VIRA
BLIZ. LOOK INH RI
HAPPENED IPE.
TO BE INFECTED WIT VUSLOOKING AF
SEVERE ILLSSNDOR
UNVACCINATED. SURGES, THE FIIN
HOSPITALS ASRS WARN
K
STAFFER.
CREATE HUMANS TO PROVIDE THAT
STAFFINA CHALLENGE
EVERYWHE WHAS THIS WINTEENT WHIM
UC IMMUNITY.T IN A SETBACK TNTSE
SAW TESTINT
A DELAUNE SECOND QUARTER
OF NEXT >> YOU OUGHT TGHT DOSEHU
DON'T LIKE THEELAY,
THAT'S WHAT THEY A
A LOT OF  J
USN WITH SCHOOL
QUAN TSES.
>>RESENTED THING AND IT IS A PID
S ACTUALIE
LOS ANGELES UNT THIS IS IS
STEAD OFHAT'S CURRENTL
HAVEO QUARANTINEOR 14 DA.REALLYO
SCRAMBLE AND FIGURE OUT
FOUNINES
TRANSMISSION.THE GOAL HERE,IDS O
HAVE MOROF THE
OMICVAT --RLING.
AND IT'LL BEWI
ANDERSON.
NG LAH, APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS.
WITH AHA.
WE ARE ESPECIALLY FWAD GLAAD TO
COS, DR.RA
TITE HLT HEARD MICHAEL
RHOLM SAWE ABOUTO CE A V BCALLE.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS GETTINCT
EIGHT WEEKS.
SEE?THWHAT WE ARE ABOUT TO
>>S CLEA
THAT IY TWO TO S AND YOU JUST H
AONS OF WHAT
FOR A EANS AND, YEAH, RE
WHAT WE WOULD LISEE,
POSSIBLE PROTECTING THEMSELVES
AN
WITH BOOSTERS RDER TO LIMIT
THE CONSEQUENCES.
ANDERSON, WE STILL DON'T REALLY
KNOW -- AND THERE'S SOME
CONTROVERS-
WHETHEOMN CAUSES THEAMKINDF DIAS
FORM OF THHE WOULD I WOULD NOT
RIGHT NOW THAT MILDER BUT
WOULDN'T THAT
TURNE                          O
THE PROBLEM OFOURSE IS ITHO INF
OMICRON.CASES IN A D F
EVEN IF IT'S A LITTLE LESS
ING TO HAVE A
LOT EOL R HOSPITALS ARE ALREADY
REALLY INTEREST STRETCHED WITH
DELTA, ESPECIALLY IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE COUNTRY.
>> SO I MEAN, THNEW
SEVERE DISEASE THAN DELTAES
HAT STUDY? YOU SANO E, KW,H SO
THOIYOU EN SAYING UP T
KNOW IT'S NOT AS SEV
LKG OU KNOERSON, IT'S
PAPER THAT WASOSTED ABOUT
HOUR ANAY THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUG.
SO I AM SUNAC. JUST NEED BETTEO
PA THE INGVE
ELIGIBLE TO GET OSTER.I SAID THI
.
HES DLY SAID THE
ESTION OF REDEFINING WHO IS
FULLY VACCED
SEMANTICS.
>> I THINK IISTHERE ARE T
WHICH THAT -- THAT T TWO
WORDS ARE BEIN.
IS HAVU FULFILLED A
MANDATE FOR YOUR EMPLOYER?
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF NI
FEL O BE UR
VAINODERNA
OR PFIZER OR ONE OF J&J.
T IN ANO
CTED ASToV-2 AND ESPECLLY
OMICRON, AT  POINT M A
BOOSTER.
SO ANYBODY WHO I
N  SORT OF OF PEOPT TH CCINATIO
ELIGIBLE FOR B HAVEN'T
YOU DON'WA TO MESS WITD E ONE O
BOTE BUT THE BOOATR  ITH
ANYBGED NOW OR
OOSTED, TO
TAKE T
STILL, OBVIOUSLY, SHOULD B
WHAT SDOING TONDOORS
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW TO BE
SAFE BUT THEY STILAP
THE VIRUS IS GOINGO
YOUR MASK AT BAY IF WE FOLLOFTE
ON IF YOU E E
GATHER AT ALL IN LARGEANT TO
BE WITH PEOP WHO ARE
HE TROUBLE'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND CONSIDER, IF YOU HERING WHEN
GETTING TESTEDEFGOST T SE YOU A
WHPP HAVE A
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTION AND DKND
TO OTHER PEOPLE.
K KNOW THE PE  I SEARING AK G T
OVER TO THEIR HOUSE EVEN IF U
ARE VACCINATED, WOULD YOU MASK
BSOLUTNNING
TOMORROW N
>> SO, PFIZER'
WHO PAS WHFIZEISG A
FOR YOUNGER KIDS K
DELAYE
SAYG S, TO DO STS WAIS GOING
TO BE DELAYED I K SECONDUA.>> WB
NOT THE ANSWER YBS HOPING TO HN
THING THAT THEY ARE
ACTUAL CS
Y TO SEE WHETHER THE
DOSUFFICAN THAT OUP,APRE2 5, TH
NG TO BE A THIRD DOSE.NC
REQUIRED BUT TISG TIKE A LITTLEO
I WISHHAT THE
ANSWER BUT I'M GLAE IS DRIVING
GOT MAF MINEKIDS AND HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY HAS TS G  LIKE SHOUL
AM GOING TO BECOME
IT.
AND THERE IS CERTAINLY A LOT O
COVID E AND SOME PEOE VARIANT IT
, CL NOT JUST
RIP THE
SPEAK?
AT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
A DANGEROUS
APPROACHAYBE
LESS SEVERE, N'T KNEANESTIONING
BUT JUSTRIP HERE, D HAVING EVER
INFECTED, ERE
800,000 AMERICANS TO THIDISEASE.
SO WE JUST HAVE DOWNLL THOSE MIO
EVEN THOUGH WE ALLF .
ACS?Y TEMPTED TO SAY SASN I WAS
ITH IT
THEY BELIEVED IN THE IMPORTANCE
RTANCEUSE T SAVING LIVESL  GOIN
THE COUNTRY DECIDES TOK WITHIT S
AROUND US WHO ARE VULNLE,
WHO CAN'T DEVELO